superhero and supervillain identities
are rarely static sidekicks take over
continuity gets rewritten and heroes and
villains routinely switch sides
but even among a list of strange legacy
characters Red Hood may be one of the
oddest from his origin as one of
Batman's oldest foes to a completely
different origin involving an alternate
universe Superman
here's a rundown of Gotham's strangest
villain turned vigilante College
criminology Red Hood first appeared in
Detective Comics number 168 a story
about Batman guest lecturing at a
college to teach students criminology
oddly enough the first appearance of the
Red Hood is actually in a flashback and
Batman enlists his students to help them
solve the mystery of a criminal that
escaped him ten years ago when the Red
Hood shows back up on the college campus
to steal some priceless artifacts Batman
manages to trap him it turns out that
the Red Hood is an illiterate
groundskeeper Earl farmer boy Benson
well not quite
farmer boy had actually captured the
real Red Hood earlier so that he could
use his costume to go on his own crime
spree the real Red Hood believe it or
not it was the Joker all along giving
Batman's greatest enemy and iconic
origin
[Applause]
why a dopey groundskeeper could capture
and undress the Joker when Batman
usually can't is another story
altogether
zero year in zero year a revamped origin
story for Bruce Wayne saw him come into
conflict with the Red Hood gang a group
of criminals who enlisted ordinary
Gotham citizens to Don the trademark Red
Hood through blackmail and extortion the
leader of the gang went by Red Hood one
and his sleeper cell of Red Hood
followers managed to be a pain and Wayne
side long enough for him to create the
Batman persona
although zero year never explicitly
confirmed that Red Hood 1 was the Joker
his climactic showdown with Batman did
end in an ace chemicals warehouse which
is the birthplace of the Joker and most
continuities so readers were left to
their own conclusions still while the
Joker might have been the first Red Hood
he's certainly not the only one and
arguably not even the most famous one
the short life of Jason Todd the most
famous Red Hood and the character who's
worn the mantle the longest would be
Jason Todd former Robin originally Jason
Todd's parents were acrobats murdered by
Killer Croc until crisis on Infinite
Earths a massive event that saw DC red
conning various story threads following
crisis Jason Todd was an orphan who was
taken under Batman's wing after stealing
the tires off the Batmobile this
revamped Robin was haunted by his life
on the streets and constantly filled
with rage and despised by some readers a
1 900 number was advertised in the pages
of Batman encouraging readers to vote on
whether Jason Todd would live or die in
Detective Comics number 428 his fate was
revealed
[Music]
Jason Todd redux Jason Todd's death was
set in stone until 2002 s Batman hush
when it looked like Jason Todd had
returned from the grave a twisting arc
that brought Batman up against most of
his rogues gallery it all came to a head
when then Robin Tim Drake was kidnapped
by Jason Todd who is supposed to be
deceased as it turned out it was
actually Clayface mimicking the former
Robin while Jason's returned from the
dead had been a ruse the plot twist did
convince writer Judd Winick to bring
Jason Todd back to life for real in
under the hood how he actually came back
was a bit of a doozy involving Infinite
Crisis which had an alternate version of
Superman punching stuff so hard that he
broke time because of this reality
altering punch Jason Todd was brought
back to life and wandered the streets in
a crazed state until he returned to
Gotham with a new identity the Red Hood
as the Red Hood Jason was a lethal
vigilante killing criminals and
torturing the Joker while also coming to
blows with Batman the story arc ended
with Jason as the Red Hood poised to
become a much more lethal vigilante than
Gotham was used to Red Hood and scarlet
red hoods rivalry with the bad family
came to a head while Dick Grayson and
Damian Wayne had taken over as Batman
and Robin in a fit of jealousy Jason
started his own dynamic duo with his own
twisted child sidekick scarlet a girl
that had been horrific Lee scarred by a
super villain after Damian failed to
save her not coincidentally the story
arc involved Red Hood giving Gotham City
and number to call to vote about whether
or not to unmask Batman and Robin a
metatextual wink - Jason Todd's own
fatal phone pole animating the hood DC
adapted Jason Todd's story into an
animated feature but in the interest of
not having to explain the complicated
events of Infinite Crisis
Jason's resurrection was simplified to
be the sole product of the Lazarus Pit
but the adaptation was otherwise fairly
accurate - the comic events you want to
rule them by fear but what do you do
with the ones who aren't afraid I'm
doing what you won't I'm taking them out
Red Hood would also appear in Batman The
Brave and the bold in animated series
that deliberately featured a light tone
straight from the Silver Age in the
episode deep cover for Batman Batman
travels to earth 23 a world where the
roles of heroes and villains are
switched
Batman's counterpart is al man
the villainous leader of the injustice
syndicate while al mans arch nemesis is
the Red Hood of vigilante fighting for
justice even after being knocked into a
vat of chemicals sound familiar
considering that Jason Todd spent a
decent amount of time killing criminals
earth 23 Red Hood might actually be the
most heroic of all what what your moral
code just won't allow for that it's too
hard to cross that line Red Hood live
Gotham the live action show ostensibly
about Bruce Wayne becoming Batman has a
knack for remix in continuity for a new
audience and it's already had an impact
on the Red Hood
while Red Hood stories usually revolve
around the Joker's origin or Jason
Todd's new identity Gotham mixed it up
by positioning the Red Hood as an actual
Red Hood thought I would uh you know
spice things up when we start wearing
hoods what did it what was I supposed to
get one no when the head gear seems to
convey good luck the Media dubs the bank
robbers the Red Hood gang the criminals
begin fighting over who gets to actually
wear the item eventually the hood proves
to be not so lucky
leaving the hood in the hands of a young
boy who pantomime shooting the police no
matter who wears the identity the Red
Hood sure seems to be unlucky still at
least the gang in Gotham didn't get
dumped into a vat of chemicals or get
resurrected by an evil Superman's fit of
rage so points to Gotham thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]